for us and also in moscow diana is there
so diana um the latest is it looks as so
there is some troop
movement on the border and hopefully
for the west in the right direction
yes we've heard both from liz trust and
ben wallace last week that actions speak
louder than words yesterday we had words
from the kremlin that suggested they
wanted to go along the path of diplomacy
today we're seeing what looked like
actions the ministry of defense
announcing not very long ago that units
from the southern and western military
districts who've been on exercise around
ukraine's border are beginning to return
back to their bases and they've released
video i haven't seen yet but apparently
of columns of tanks
moving through fields and also of
weaponry being loaded onto trains and if
that is the case that is a very good
sign we have these huge military drills
ongoing with belarus at the moment
they're due to finish on the 20th and
then there are naval drills happening
also in all kind of the oceans where
russia is active and units from the
eastern military district and from the
center of russia have moved in to
participate in these exercises with
belarus which are called union resolve
but the fact that amongst all these
calls uh from the u.s that russia was
planning to invade imminently russia has
decided to actually do what sergey
shoigu the defence minister said
yesterday and that is start to pull
troops back is i think a very good sign
yesterday the defense minister said we
will be uh concluding these exercises
soon and the foreign minister sergey
lavrov who was so short with liz trust
last week said that he did think there
was still a chance of diplomacy and that
it was worth talking about these
secondary issues um of missile
deployment things like that in europe um
so i think those are signals to the west
that russia does not intend to invade
imminently we've also heard from the
foreign ministry spokeswoman saying this
day will go down in history as the day
when western war propaganda did not work
um and not a single shot was fired
that's quite typical of her pretty
flamboyant rhetoric but um as olaf
schultz the german chancellor comes to
meet with vladimir putin some good signs
at least of russia trying to de-escalate
um but again there's very little trust
between russia and the west so i think
it has to continue in this direction
before we all
uh breathe a sigh of relief before i let
you
go down i just want to um read this and
see see what your reaction is just in
from the russian foreign ministry
spokeswoman and that is maria zakharova
from her telegram which is basically
like a what's up she says 15th of
february 2022 today will go down in
history as the day western war
propaganda failed
humiliated and destroyed without a
single shot
fired what's she hoping to achieve from
that do you think diana
i mean she loves that kind of thing
that's absolutely typical
of maria zakharova um i i think that uh
the the russia has always built this
talk of imminent invasion from the u.s
especially as western hysteria and it
does make it easier for russia to back
down if it's public back home think this
whole thing was fanned up by the west
and that russia never had any intention
to invade i mean this has not been
played you know in the russian state
media as anything other than um an
attempt by the west to fan the flames of
war while russia is trying to pursue its
legitimate security concerns um so i
think that statement from zakharova is
is is playing into that completely i
think it's also worth mentioning
interestingly that today there will be a
resolution in the duma about whether
which is the russian parliament whether
to declare donbass the two republics in
donbass donetsk and luhansk independent
if minsk those agreements to try and
secure peace in donbass don't what
doesn't work then that would give russia
an easy get out clause effectively to
say well we tried our best
but we must look after our own citizens
and therefore uh we must declare these
regions independent and then possibly
send in troops to protect our people if
minsk works then they get more of a sort
of
a
leeway within the ukrainian constitution
so there's a lot of shenanigans still
going on behind the scenes and we heard
the u.s talk about possible false flag
operations liz trust also i think you
hear
as part of the kind of kremlin
propaganda all the time the fact that of
course if there is a provocation then we
must go in and protect our citizens in
donbass you heard that yesterday late
yesterday from russia's representative
to the eu so it's it's it's it's all out
there for us to see and read
you know you don't need much evidence to
show that
uh whatever happens the kremlin has an
array of options that they can sort of
act on should they decide but i think
for now the mood music is
going the right way for the west